a top eight qualifying match we gave you
guys a little bit of who was still left
in you want to check out the progress
for sales
that's how about say hashtag exclamation
point bracket we have our next match
this
is loser's side no this is winner's side
we have joy fury
versus dial it wave oh man we're going
straight into it and
real quick i want to give a shout out to
chenzo one of the most positive
and wholesome tech and streamers that
there is around place king
his community and his stream is always
great if you want to learn and get into
tekken
either way let's get into the matchup oh
get into this matchup with joey fury
wearing grandma couch marduk right now
my man looks like he works at a casino
dude
as a bouncer
i thought he's gonna do the whole stream
i mean he he looks like he's he's
rocking the casino carpet or something
right exactly man and it's gross
okay oh man joey fury you know he has
been
definitely putting in work in a lot of
these online tournaments with that
marduk
but again if marduk doesn't work you
know he has that other weapon
ready he has that [ __ ] rum too so
first off let's just talk about the
homie uh
joey fury equinox's joy fury has one of
his main training partners and as she
plays fang so i feel like he he
definitely should have a lot of
experience in this matchup
yeah having experience in the matchup is
definitely going to be there
however because maybe you train too much
with nasty now she does play a certain
style
it might change things because daily
wave he's a different kind of thing he's
not the same type of fang player
he definitely makes use of the reverse
campo and even the forward kenpo much
more than we see from other
thing players yeah i mean and that's
kind of the things that come with it
they keep uh
they make changes to a lot of these
characters but i feel like fang is one
of the characters
that has been good from jump anyway so
if you right you're right if you're too
used to one
bang player going and fighting somebody
else especially who uses the tools a
little differently is gonna be uh you're
gonna have to change it up a little bit
and i'm gonna tell you right now this
offense from dialect wave to just stay
in jory fury's face with no fear i mean
fang does have stuff like back one
great pokes back four down three no
break on the ground and pound
um and that's able to keep marduk honest
i feel like better than most characters
but you still have to call it out and
joey fury is aware of it
they dancing a little bit
the lava walk oh my gosh
look at these pokes get off of me hands
off the ponytail
if there's ever a throw that you want to
avoid it's that one that throw is gonna
it's gonna end your your round pretty
much
okay nice
that was good to close out i moved four
what you gonna do against that kick i
mean it's like a tree trunk hitting you
right you're getting
swept at your legs that big old down
four from marduk oh protect your legs
what are you doing
he's going more into bail two though the
counter hit push this could be big
damage
look at this
oh joey fury just chopping away
and starting to run away with it oh nice
cancel into the low but he blocked it
though
that was a good block he's gonna have to
be careful how he approaches this
the down four and we just saw that kind
of snowball
out of control for dylaway looking so
good in that first game up against joy
fury and joy fury was seeming like
at first i was like man he is really
taking it to joyful with these pokes and
you know especially considering how much
practice joy fury has versus of
seasoned fang player um but then as you
saw what happened was the minute
the minute joey fury got the scent he
was like ah
you're playing this way huh got it chase
them through
through the woods gets the rounds back
takes that first game this
is winner's side here so there's still
games to play for both of these players
but you want to stay on the winner's
side
so you can get closer to that winners
finals and you know obviously the grand
finals to be our king of the hill
champion here
i can't stress how important it is to
win this opening winners match in top
eight
just because it puts you into the
winners final and it lets you play
longer sets throughout the entire
tournament that is such an important
thing
especially when it comes to you know
being able to calm down and adjust
between matches
so again this is very important joey
fury and i wave gonna be battling it out
for it
i saw joey in the matchup you know he
really started to make adjustments
and started opening up his opponent by
going for different timings of those low
attacks and they really started to add
up over time
and then once the lows started getting
in there i feel like there was no coming
back from it especially towards that
last round
no that's definitely true you have to
you really have to
be careful um it's one of those theme
rolling kind of things especially
you know that dialet wave understands
that joy fury has experience in this
matchup so it's more about keeping him
on his toes
dylan wave i'm not sure if he has extra
characters or anything like that
but when you get in these kind of
situations you need to be prepared to
switch it up
more drastically considering how much
experience is on the side of joy fury
a little slower paced on the side of
dial-a-wave this time that's cause
they're doing math now man we geometric
plane oh that's true man
you gotta add it up let's see what he
does he goes for the tackle and that is
another key weapon
that joey fury uses to complement his
entire arsenal seeing how his opponents
react to that tackle but then
because they're going to be scared of
the tackle it really opens up everything
else
those down four start to add up mark has
a pretty strong throw game as well big
launcher we saw this in the last game
the lead hit him with the shoulder
nice low perry with the with the reed
dialect wave dial it in
first round goes the fan way
okay he sights up that was the right
opportunity there joey fury
kind of scouting what his opponent's
going to do
here we go got him with the mid and
that's going to hurt look at the life
deficit
uh oh the harada care package kicking in
check your mail
you got something special waiting it's
extra life not enough to get the round
though
joy fury answers back round for round
pound for pound let's go
here we go joey fury again with that
momentum let's see if he's able to carry
it over into this third round
goes for the knee here we go evasive
action oh gotta be careful those lows
are gonna add up again
a back door i like that you have to
start going war to some of those folks
joy fury
really offensive keeping a dialect wave
honest in some of these situations
you know there's one really scary thing
about joey fury now he has new access
to that new marduk move that he got uh
from this season
very fast it also knocks down if he has
an opportunity to use it in that
mid-range it could
prove to be uh troublesome here for fang
but it doesn't matter
look at that just pure dominance here
from joey fury
great awareness down 4-1 counter hit
takes the ground
and you know daily wave in the last king
the hill event where we had uh combat
combat
combat combat he was able to make it to
the very end and he put on a great show
and actually took uh glaciating to the
final match
he might have not have this opportunity
if he's going to have to really fight it
out of the losers but he's fighting back
now
you see a final match final round in
this match right here for dylan wave he
needs this round to stay alive but not
gonna break the ground a pound that's
not good
that's not a good way to start this
potential final round double tackle do
it again
joey fury a little bit over half-life
oh the low parry and this is what i was
talking about it kind of steamrolls joey
fury
getting the lead and the boy you might
be dead oh real close
real close opted to go for the damage
here it doesn't matter
seven golden letters the parfait
complete
look at that joey fury moving on winners
finals
okay winners finals for joy fury um and
we can talk a little bit about what joey
fury's
done on the side of icfc as well didn't
start off the season so well especially
when you had you know bing chang
coto core shadow glaciating all making
those